a hiker who got lost in mount rainier
national park in washington state
is on the mend after being brought back
to life in what his doctors are calling
a miraculous recovery i would concur
rescuers found michael nipinski
unconscious eight days ago
he had become disorientated in freezing
white-out conditions
nipinski and the medical team that saved
him spoke to our lead national
correspondent david begno
michael dapinski is the kind of guy that
hikes just about every week
it's a passion that he says he turned to
to overcome a drug addiction that nearly
killed him
i used to be a very unhealthy sickly man
and i got into hiking and changed my
lifestyle
the 45 year old was exploring mount
rainier national park on november 7th
when he got caught in freezing whiteout
conditions
did you have time to worry and get
scared
i was worried and scared definitely
but i was just taking really small steps
you know because i couldn't see anything
that was the last thing he remembers the
next day
rescuers found him unconscious but with
a pulse
a navy helicopter airlifted him to
harbor view medical center in seattle
where his heart stopped cpr was
performed on him for
45 minutes as doctors hooked him up to
an ecmo machine
which temporarily takes over heart and
lung function
by adding oxygen and removing carbon
dioxide from a patient's blood
he went into cardiac arrest and usually
when people are this sick it's not
reversible
but because we had this ecmo technology
that allowed us to support his body
while we warmed him up and then got his
heart restarted
we were able to get his heart started
back up after two days of trying to get
a reaction from him
nurse whitney holland called out to
michael and he opened his eyes and i was
like oh
crap like that was very purposeful
uh and i i said michael are you with me
and he like turned and looked at me and
nodded his head like of course i'm with
you why would you ask that question
uh and gave me a big smile michael what
is it
what are you thinking listening to this
i love all of it
i was very happy to see that they
everybody here was beyond caring and
just amazing will you go climbing again
yes i will do it more safely next time
but it's a
lifestyle for me he is grateful as ever
for cbs this morning i'm david beckner
oh what a team michael that nurse
whitney and those guys didn't give up on
him yeah that's amazing yeah
the amazing team and i love that nurse's
reaction crap yeah
it opened his eyes i love that michael's
gonna go hike again they always hike
again
yeah how do we feel about that at least
don't go by yourself but i'm sure in
some ways he feels hiking saved his life
and i think it did it's time his doctor
saved his life again
we're glad he's okay and thank goodness
for the staff that worked on you
and let you down